director Matt Reeves ditches a
traditional origin story for his latest
movie The Batman instead the 2022 film
begins with Bruce Wayne well into his
second year of vigilante work in Gotham
City he's a brutal force on the streets
as he breezes through fights with thugs
and seasoned gangsters alike to protect
the innocent although he's definitely
still a little rough around the edges
regular citizens aren't sure whether the
Dark Knight is a hero or a monster and
he still has an incredibly uneasy
relationship with the Gotham City Police
Department despite the unquestioning
trust Jim Gordon places in him things in
Gotham go from bad to worse when the
Riddler rears his ugly mask covered mug
to Target institutional corruption and
Gotham he starts with the mayor from
there Batman and Selena Kyle AKA
Catwoman try to figure out why the
Riddler is hell-bent on tearing the city
down unfortunately that isn't so easy
when the Killer's mysterious game is
built upon riddles mind-bending
Mysteries and a criminal conspiracy the
early reception of the movie has been
incredibly positive and as of this video
it currently has an 86 percent critic
score on Rotten Tomatoes with what to
watch saying that it quote fires on all
cylinders but like every good comic book
movie The Batman ends with a dramatic
fight to save the day it's time to look
at the hero's tactics in the Gotham
Arena brawl careful spoilers ahead the
Riddler's plan to destroy Gotham's
infrastructure culminates with the
detonation of seven bombs around the
city's sea wall flooding the downtown
area thousands of Gotham citizens
congregating downtown to celebrate Bella
reale's mayoral win rush to the Gotham
Arena to escape the high waters as they
seek safety a gang of Riddler's
followers all dressed in matching
uniforms opened fire from rigging high
above the arena thankfully Batman and
Catwoman are on the scene to take them
down and save the people down below but
the Caped Crusader might have broken his
rule against killing in the midst of
fighting back historically whether it's
in film TV Comics or video games Batman
always makes a point that he doesn't
kill criminals this rule stems from the
trauma of watching his parents die that
night in Crime Alley however during the
Batman finale as the gunman working for
the Riddler take shots at Batman at
close range he deflects the bullets back
at the shooters which sends a few of
them slumping to the floor it's not
clear if their wounds are fatal but it
doesn't exactly look good
obviously there's the suspension of
disbelief here the audience doesn't see
Batman kill anyone nor do we see the
Riddler's gunmen die in the fight even
the lone goon he nearly beats to a pulp
is saved when Jim Gordon intervenes as
such it's easy to assume that Batman
stuck to his one rule but this grim and
gritty world that Matt Reeves has
created it wouldn't be a stretch to
think that if they died because of the
fight Batman wouldn't be too bothered by
it because the film ends on a
surprisingly hopeful note maybe the bat
will have a different Outlook when it
comes to brutalizing his foes from now
on in the last decade or so the debates
over whether Batman inadvertently kills
people has become a hot button topic
even hitting a fever pitch with the dark
Knight's actions in Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice Zack Snyder's second
movie in the DC extended Universe sees
Ben Affleck's hero dish out some brutal
punishment to lick sleuthor's goons
across the film whether it's his chaotic
car chase through Gotham Harbor or that
Savage Warehouse fights the older
version of The Dark Knight doesn't pull
his punches at all realistically it's
all about the story that Batman happens
to be in at the time the no killing rule
can be pushed or broken depending on
which director or author is controlling
Batman's story with Robert Pattinson led
the Batman it's clear that this version
of the hero is still questioning his
approach to fighting crime even he
acknowledges he needs to be a better
symbol to the people of Gotham so
although he's not too bothered by
deflecting bullets back at his foes he
is at least trying to be better
obviously there's an argument to be made
that Bruce Wayne isn't actively trying
to kill the Riddler's followers while in
Batman mode he's just defending himself
in the most idealized versions of the
character like Batman the Animated
Series the specifics about his no
killing rule definitely matter but when
the story is directly analyzing who
Batman is and how he's growing as a hero
there's a little bit of breathing room
when it comes to his violent streak
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
the Batman are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]